cheyenne high school was placed on  lockdown for a few hours this morning  ccsd police say officers detained a  student on campus and found that student  was in possession of a firearm the  school was quickly placed on lockdown  during the investigation our camera  capturing these images of several patrol  vehicles outside the campus as well as  k-9 units some parents were outraged  over the lack of communication  i come here every day to pick her up at  12. that's police it's incident every  day every day they need either more  police staff they need a better way of  communication with the parents because  anything can happen and you have no idea  until you come up here because i didn't  see the news  and i didn't get a call  well the school principal notified  families of the incident shortly after  the lockdown was lifted they suggest  parents should talk about safety with  their kids reminding them to never  hesitate to report anything suspicious  or a safety issue